herr präsident meine damen und herren
frau bundeskanzlerin sie haben im
vergangenen jahr gegen den rat auf der
opposition die pandemie bekämpfung in
die ministerpräsidentenkonferenz
verlagert ein gremium was das
grundgesetz nicht kennt dieser weg hier
weg der pandemie bekämpfung ist
gescheitert die im kanzleramt
geschaffenen handlungs leitplanken haben
das land in die dritte corona welle
manövriert wir haben seit november einen
permanenten halb lockdown und sind immer
nach der welle es ist uns nicht gelungen
hier wirklich eine veränderung
vorzunehmen
dann kam der das bekannte osterhofen
desaster nach der letzten mpk ich hätte
erwartet dass sie direkt danach mit
wirkungsvollen maßnahmen der pandemie
bekämpfung in den bundestag zurückkehren
sie haben bei anne will gesagt viel zeit
haben wir nicht mehr das ist drei wochen
her passiert ist danach nichts sie sagen
das virus versteht kein zögern aber die
lage ist jetzt so dass es bereits zehn
nach zwölf ist die inzidenz steigt die
auslastung der intensivbetten steigt es
gibt dramatische appelle nahezu täglich
von den intensivmedizinern die folgen
bei jungen menschen longo wird werden
immer deutlicher sichtbar
das ist die reale situation das versagen
der verantwortlichen im umgang mit
dieser krise erscheint vielen bürger
inzwischen als unverzeihlich meine damit
ja dazu
dazu gibt es eine grafische
kommunikation und wir sehen doch in
anderen ländern lieber herr linder ich
muss darauf hinweisen in großbritannien
öffnen die papst in israel öffnen die
strände
ich kann ihnen sagen die diese länder
aus der pandemie gekommen sind über
millionenfache impfung und über
konsequentes handeln meine damen und
herren in den usa werden täglich vier
millionen menschen geimpft und bei uns
liegen vier millionen impfdosen rumpf
gesundheitsminister hat dafür keine
reale erklärung inzwischen sind 22
prozent der amerikaner vollständig
geimpft 57 prozent der israelis 24
prozent der chilenen und bei uns der
zentrale punkt warum deutschland beim
impfen so sogar unter dem eu-schnitt
liegt ist ihrem versagen und der
bürokratie geschuldet vier monate zu
spät bestellt das sind die vier monate
dies jetzt für die bürgerinnen und
bürger besonders schwer machen meine
damen und herren das ist die reale lage
und da wo die bundesregierung in der
pflicht war haben sie es eben vielfach
nicht hinbekommen was macht eigentlich
die korona waren etwas ist denn
eigentlich damit sie gucken gerade
darauf wies mit dir steht was ist denn
mit den bundesweiten test bis heute
bestehen diese mängel vor ort und das
infektionsschutzgesetz behebt eben
keinen davon
es ist gut dass die bundesregierung auf
den weg zurück in den deutschen
bundestag ist aber es ist inakzeptabel
es ist inakzeptabel dass sie den
bundestag faktisch mit diesem gesetz
nicht stärken sondern machten und selbst
ein blankoscheck haben wollen das ist
keine stärkung des demokratischen
verfahren
sondern eine abrissbirne des
parlamentarismus dann fehlt ihnen nach
14 monaten vor allem in die
ausgangssperre ein ja und es war eine
bundesweite ausgangssperre ist doch
richtig es gibt lange ausgangssperren
ist auch möglich dass auch völlig in
ordnung aber das ist so ist das so
widersinnig wie die oster ruhe es ist
rechtlich höchst bedenklich es ein
grundrechtseingriff und die aerosol
forscher die sagen natürlich eine ganz
andere position die gefahr lauert in den
innenräumen
es ist doch so dass der abendspaziergang
oder das stalking stellen sie sich mal
vor sie haben home office gehabt sie
haben homeschooling gemacht und dann
abends um 21 uhr wollen sie vielleicht
allein als alleinerziehende mutter noch
einmal für eine halbe stunde raus und
das dürfen sie nicht mit ihrem geschenk
kontakt beschränkungen ja aber das ist
nicht die lösung impfen das ist der
schlüssel wo ist denn der angekündigte
im probe wo sind denn die
produktionsstätten 9
wo ist eine nationale strategie nicht
die ministerpräsidenten sind das problem
sondern es sind die minister der cdu und
csu im bund sie haben wir schlecht
regiert deswegen ist die lage so wie sie
ist und das ist übrigens besonders
verwerflich war sie hier so laut sind
herr brinkhaus es besonders verwerflich
dass die union das ganze land mit ihren
personalproblem belästigt es ist
verwerflich dass sich die schwersten
tage der pandemie und sie reden über
sünder und lasche werden im nächsten
bundestag oppositionsführer ist lassen
sie das endlich das wäre sinnvoll
das wäre sinnvoll wenn der bund der bund
war während der gesamten pandemie nicht
in der lage für schulen luftfilter und
für lehrer rechtzeitig impfstoffe zu
beschaffen und nun soll das kanzleramt
autorisiert werden in passau oder in
rostock die schulen zu schließen das ist
niemandem zu vermitteln meine damen und
herren das ist wie das ist die situation
kinder kinder sind bei ihnen nämlich der
blinde fleck lieberherr brinkhaus kinder
sind bei ihnen der blinde fleck in der
pandemie bekämpfung die schulen hatten
bei ihnen nie priorität zu kindern und
in zu familien sind sie in der pandemie
bekämpfung hama hart aber in der
wirtschaft da sind sie wachs war ich das
ist die situation
haben sie eigentlich sorge dass die
union keine spenden für die
bundestagswahl kriegt sie haben wir elf
leute die wegen korruption letztlich
zurückgetreten ist fc eigene tasche das
ist doch bei der union derzeit der fall
ihm fehlt immer noch der focus pandemie
bekämpfung bedeutet immer auch
einschränkungen privaten bei ihnen bei
den haushalten aber es geht nie darum
die wirtschaft auch mal in den fokus es
geht nicht darum die wirtschaft
anzuhalten darum geht es nicht aber es
muss darum gehen das arbeitsleben mit
sicherer zu machen und ansteckung zu
verhindern
kein kotau vor den wirtschaftsverbänden
kontakt beschränkungen ja aber nicht so
wie sie das hier machen was wir den
schülern zugute
das muss bei unternehmen doch gang und
jede sein das wäre die wahrheit frau
bundeskanzlerin die fraktion die linke
kann so ihrem gesetzentwurf nicht
zustimmen ich hoffe auf veränderungen im
parlamentarischen verfahren
sie erhalten von meiner fraktion kein
blankoscheck für ihre pandemie
bekämpfung das gesetz ist kein schnelles
instrument zum brechen der dritten welle
es ist vielfach autoritäre symbolpolitik
verbarrikadieren sie sich nicht im
kanzleramt sondern ich rate unabhängig
von dem gesetz wir brauchen endlich
einen breiten dialog ein dialog auch von
virologen und ärzten aber im auch
pädagogen psychologen
wirtschaftswissenschaftler künstler
gewerkschaften usw
nur dann werden wir vertrauen
zurückgewinnen können das ist das
wichtigste kapitel kapital was sie haben
und das haben sie leider vielfach
missbraucht herzlichen dank